[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
da sind wir wieder wie immer mit einer
tödlichen Geschichte diesmal sind aber
auch ein bisschen Glamour und
tv-spannung dabei ich bin Toni Heyer und
bestreite auch diese Fallakte wieder mit
dem Master of Mord Desaster Mirko
Kasimir hört sich in diesem Begriff
ausgedacht hallo Toni heute geht es um
einen Todesfall der Deutschland
innerhalb von drei Jahrzehnten gleich
zweimal aufgewühlt hat einmal als er
passierte und dann noch einmal als
eigentlich längst schon Gras über die
Sache gewachsen war und ich finde weil
die Protagonistin lautstark
selbstbewusst und eigenwillig ist kannst
du sie mal vorstellen Toni
es geht heute um Ingrid van Bergen ich
lese mal aus dem Lebenslauf vor
sie wurde am 15 Juni 1931 in Danzig
geboren und wuchs im damaligen
Ostpreußen in Masuren auf dort spielte
sich schon als Kind in Theaterstücken
ihr Vater fiel an der Ostfront und kurz
vor Kriegsende floh die Mutter mit ihren
vier Kindern nach Dänemark unterwegs
Sankt das Schiff dass sie über die
Ostsee dorthin bringen sollte aber die
kleine Familie wurde gerettet bis 1948
lebte sie in einem dänischen Lager nach
der Rückkehr 1950 nach Deutschland
machte Ingrid van Bergen ihr Abitur und
schrieb sich an der Staatlichen
Hochschule für Musik Hamburg ein ihr
Traum Schauspielerin und Sängerin werden
ja und das ist ja auch gelungen ja wobei
sie sich erst hocharbeiten musste
nachdem sie bei den kleinen Fischen in
München und in der Berliner
Kabarettgruppe die Stachelschweine
mitgewirkt hatte bekam Ingrid 1954 ihre
erste Filmrolle in Bildnis einer
unbekann
dann nahm alles Fahrt auf insgesamt
spielte sie in 200 Filmen alter Schwede
und wie sieht es mit dem Privatleben aus
davon hatte sie viel Ingrid van Bergen
war vier Mal verheiratet unter anderem
mit dem Kabarettisten Erich sehenke der
war auch Vater ihrer Tochter Andrea
außerdem noch mit dem Schauspieler
Michael Hinz der unter anderem den Onkel
Quentin in der Serie fünf Freunde
spielte mit Hinz hatte van Bergen die
Tochter Carolin die 1990 mit 26 Jahren
starb jetzt haben wir schon ganz viele
Eckdaten aber die sagen noch nicht so
viel über den Menschen dahinter also ich
finde die Frau wirklich spannend ich
meine sie wird in eine Zeit geboren in
der Frauen auf der Leinwand noch
meistens die entzückenden Dummchen
spielen sollten damals haben auch viele
Frauen eine Oktave höher gesprochen weil
das niedlich wirken sollte so ein
richtiger Quatsch aus heutiger Sicht
die Ingrid van Bergen war aber von
Anfang an der Type gerne auch mal so
Abteilung gefährlicher Vamp ich habe
hier meinen Ausschnitt gefunden da
spielt sie eine Mademoiselle Gloria im
Film das Geheimnis der gelben Narzissen
von
1961 ich habe mich niemals im Walde
versteckt ich hab als Kind schon das
eine entdeckt sieht mich ein Mann denkt
der gleich an l'amour
in bei mir ist alles nur
wenn es die Männer wie oft schon
verwirrt mich mit brillianten und Nerz
zu verführen weiß ich das liegt nur an
meine Figur
[Musik]
wenn bei mir ist jeder zollnatur wow ein
Vamp im Wirtschaftswunderland genau sie
war bekannt für ihre rauchige Stimme und
entsprechend wurde sie gerne besetzt als
Bardame [__] oder Untreue Hausfrau und
im Laufe der Jahre spielte sie
beispielsweise mit Leuten die damals so
richtig große Namen hatten also in
Deutschland oh wie Fischer joachim
Fuchsberger und Heinz Rühmann und
international zum Beispiel Christopher
Lee Klaus Kinski Kirk Douglas oder
robert Mitchum Heidi die kanntest du
musst dich natürlich Google aber da
waren schon scharfe Typen dabei die
Redaktion hat uns ein BamS Interview
rausgesucht von 2021 und da wurde sie
gefragt ob es am Set geknistert hat und
sie hat gesagt die Männer flirteten alle
mit mir ich war schließlich mal ein
attraktives Weib die Flirterei gehörte
zum Prozedere das war einfach so
ich war aber immer in festen Händen und
habe das nie wirklich ernst genommen
also Toni wir haben jetzt ein Bild von
Ingrid van Bergen und wir können uns
jetzt den 70er Jahren nähern da ist die
schöne selbstbewusste Ingrid mit der
rauchigen Stimme sie hat sich nicht nur
als Vamp in Filmen zu einer der
bekanntesten Schauspielerinnen gemausert
sie gehört fest ins Showgeschäft singen
zur tanzt ist regelmäßig zu Gast in den
großen Schoß der Zeit wie einer wird
gewinnen dalidali oder am laufenden Band
na ich heraus du musst es diese alten
Geschichten nicht googeln du kennst sie
noch von damals oder naja teils das ist
selbst für einen mittelalten Knochen wie
mich eine Weile her aber weiter im
Geschehen in den 70ern ist Ingrid van
Bergen nicht nur dauernd in der
Öffentlichkeit aktiv auch in ihren
Privatleben ist das ein wildes Jahrzehnt
Toni du hast eine Art
beziehungsorganigramm vor dir liegen ja
also
in den 70ern ist sie bereits zweimal
geschieden und zweifache Mutter aus
ihrer Ehe mit dem Kabarettisten Erich
sehenke stammt Tochter Andrea und
Tochter Carolin aus der Ehe mit dem
Schauspieler Michael Hinz
1972 beginnt eine äußerst kurze Ehe mit
einem modekaufmann namens Heinz Pape die
hält sechs Monate das folgt eine
Beziehung mit einem Bauwagen Großhändler
der Michael Haas heißt
1977 kommt Ingrid van Bergen schließlich
mit Klaus Knarz zusammen eine
schicksalhafte Konstellation wenn ich
das mal so sagen darf ja der übernehme
ich mal der Finanzmakler Klaus Klausi
Knarz gilt in der Schickeria als Playboy
der die Nähe schöner oft auch käuflicher
Frauen sucht das weiß Ingrid van Bergen
vielleicht nicht als sie ihn auf einem
Pferdehof kennenlernt oder vielleicht
will sie es nicht wissen die beiden
treffen aufeinander als Knarz in seinem
Jaguar vorfährt
halten sich darüber dass der
Scheibenwischer noch an ist es funkt
schon nach wenigen Wochen zieht der
adrette Klausi zu Ingrid van Bergen und
ihren zwei Töchtern in deren Villa in
Pöcking bei München wobei Knarz nicht so
oft zu Hause ist auch am Tag der alles
verändern sollte am 2 februar
1977 Ingrid und Klaus sind mittags in
einem Restaurant essen gehen dann
auseinander Klaus will abends nach Hause
kommen er kommt aber erst in der Nacht
was dann geschah lass dich in der Presse
damals so in der Nacht gegen 1:30 Uhr so
der Polizeibericht teilte eine
geschiedene Schauspielerin 45 Jahre aus
Starnberg telefonisch mit das in ihrem
Anwesen ein Mann angeschossen worden sei
ein von seiner Frau getrennt lebender
Finanzmakler 33 Jahre so die ersten
Feststellungen von Notarzt und Polizei
und Tatort sei durch Schüsse tödlich
verletzt worden gegen die Dame die ihren
heimkehrenden Partner lediglich durch
bedrohen mit einer Faustfeuerwaffe
erschrecken wollte wurde Haftbefehl
wegen dringenden Verdachts des
Totschlags erlassen kurz gesagt sie hat
ihren unzuverlässigen windigen Typen
umgelegt das ist meine Ansage die
polizeilichen Ermittlungen sind nicht
kompliziert als Beamter eintreffen
finden Sie die Tatwaffe vor das Opfer
und eine 45-jährige Ingrid von Bergen
die sich nach eigenen Angaben nur noch
an wenig erinnern kann das ist ja nicht
mal unwahrscheinlich schließlich hat die
gute sich ordentlich eingekippt in ihrer
Wut und aufgelöstheit und dazu wohl auch
noch Schlaftabletten genommen richtig
Toni das war auf jeden Fall auch Teil
der Verteidigungsstrategie und damit
wären wir auch schon beim Prozess okay
bevor du loslegst das Spektakel müssen
wir uns bitte mal kurz vorstellen da ist
eine der bekanntesten Schauspielerin
ihrer Zeit wunderschön spielt oft Vans
und frustrierte Ehefrauen macht ständig
Schlagzeilen mit ihrem Liebesleben und
dann liegt ihr aktueller Lover
erschossen auf ihrem Anwesen mehr geht
kaum tatsächlich als der Prozess ein
paar Monate später beginnt warten
hunderte Schaulustige vor dem Münchner
Justizpalast die Polizei hält die Menge
in Schach vertreten wird Ingrid van
Bergen von Rolf Bossi dem bekannten
Strafverteidiger der dadurch noch
bekannter wird ja das Gefängnis kann er
ja aber trotzdem nicht ersparen genau am
27 juli 1977 wird sie wegen Totschlags
zu 7 Jahren Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
nach Verbüßung von zwei Dritteln der
Strafe in der JVA Aichach in Bayern
wurde sie am 2 oktober 1981 wegen guter
Führung Vorzeit sich entlassen okay wir
können die Akten der Justiz jetzt mal
beiseite legen und gucken uns mal an was
danach war dafür gibt es eine schöne
Floskel und die lautet folgendermaßen es
gelang ihr zunächst nicht an ihre alten
Erfolge anzuknüpfen heißt was also sie
spielte Theater drehte einen Film mit
Rosa von Praunheim das war ein Statement
denn Frauenheim galt damals als Schwule
krawallschachtel im ambitionierten
deutschen Autorenfilm
sie spielte bei Fernsehserien mit dir
heute kein Mensch mehr kennt aber nach
und nach fasste sie wieder Fuß war auch
im Megaerfolg unser Lehrer dr Specht zu
sehen und Mirko aus all den Nachrichten
über die Familie habe ich mir hier noch
was zu Tochter Carolin rausgesucht die
wär am Anfang schon erwähnt hatten das
war das Kind aus der Ehe mit Michael
Hinz Carolin wurde auch Schauspielerin
machte in zwei Fernsehserien mit und
wurde dann mit Hörspielen bekannt
1990 wurde dann bei ihr Krebs in einem
sehr späten Stadium festgestellt und sie
starb bei einer OP und ich kann noch
ergänzen dass Ingrid van Bergen ab 1994
rund 7 Jahre auf Mallorca lebte und sich
dort für den Tierschutz einsetzte und
jetzt kommen wir zu der Zeit in der auch
ich junges Huhn Ingrid von Bergen
kennengelernt habe dem legendären
Auftritt im Dschungelcamp den hat damals
unser Kollege Daniel Krämer ganz
hervorragend zusammengefasst
nico hat sich das Exemplar aus dem
Archiv geholt da steht als Überschrift
deutsche Kriminalgeschichte
gruselgeständnis im Dschungelcamp und
dann heißt es weiter am Tag vor der Tat
sei beim Mittagessen noch alles
harmonisch gewesen
wir wollten abends die Sauna und den
Kamin anmachen doch zu Hause in ihrer
Villa am Starnberger See wartet van
Bergen vergebens auf ihn ich rief ihn
auf Autotelefon an keine Antwort da fing
ich an zu trinken
Rotwein aus dem Kühlschrank und eine
Flasche Gin ich saß vor dem brennenden
Kamin und habe alle gemeinsamen Fotos in
den Kamin geworfen gegen 1 Uhr früh kam
Klaus Knarz
ich war so weggetreten erzählt Ingrid
von Bergen er ging ins Schlafzimmer und
holte sein reisekofferchen und seines um
38er Spezial die Waffe hatte er oft bei
sich
es war der Revolver mit dem Inhalt von
Bergen schließlich ihren Liebhaber gegen
1:30 Uhr mit zwei Schüssen tötete hier
wird sie wieder zitiert es kam zu einem
Handgemenge er sagte mir dass er jetzt
geht für immer und dann passierte was
auch immer irgendwas ist da passiert
dann dass ich mich nicht mehr erinnern
kann
irgendwann erwachte von Bergen aus ihrem
Rausch ich dachte jetzt ist er
verschwunden da ging ich die Treppe
runter und da lag er vor dem Haus
die Tatwaffe fand die Polizei später im
Pool Zitat Ende boah was für eine krasse
Schilderung und das auch noch im
Fernsehen es passt natürlich super zu
einer Schauspielerin und das Ingrid auch
noch Dschungelkönigin wurde Kult wie aus
einem Drehbuch war übrigens auch was die
Bild am 4 februar 1977 über die Aussage
von Knarz Mutter schreibt kurz nach 1
Uhr früh rief der Finanzmakler und
jaguarfahrer knarzt vom ersten Stock aus
seine Mutter eine Ärztin an es ist alles
vorbei Mutter sagte er ich gehe zu
meiner Frau zurück und dann fügte er
hinzu Ingrid und ich wir haben uns in
aller Freundschaft getrennt
in diesem Augenblick hörte die Ärztin
durchs Telefon zwei Schüsse ah das ist
so heftig okay Mirko letzte Seite der
Akte was steht drauf nach allem was wir
wissen lebt Ingrid van Bergen mit ihren
über 90 Jahren in der Lüneburger Heide
sie braucht zwar eine Gehhilfe ist aber
ansonsten wohlauf das ist wirklich ein
langes und wirklich wirklich
ereignisreiches Leben ich meine Klaus
knarzf Fehlverhalten das rechtfertigt
noch lange nicht dass sie ihn umlegt
aber ich muss sagen ich kann sie ein
bisschen nachvollziehen dass sie sich
zumindest betrinkt und sauer ist ich
meine wie oft habe ich das schon erlebt
dass der Typ einfach nicht nach Hause
kommt und sich irgendwo rumtreibt und
einfach nicht meldet also da war ich
schon auf 180 und habe mir das ein oder
andere Mal auch meine Flasche Wein
aufgemacht aber ihn umzulegen das ist
schon noch mal eine andere Sache ich
finde es aber wirklich erstaunlich wie
sie sich wieder zurück ins Leben bzw an
die Spitze des Showgeschäfts gekämpft
hat Toni du hast doch keine Waffe zu
Hause und würde sicherlich auch keine
Gewalt einsetzen naja also ich habe zwei
schaumstoffschwerter zu Hause
okay okay damit lässt sich die Situation
vielleicht bereinigen ja und das auch
ganz sicher ohne Blut das war Tatort
Deutschland für dieses Mal wir haben den
Fall Ingrid van Bergen erzählt mit
Auszügen aus dem Archiv von Bild und
BILD am SONNTAG einem Spiegel Artikel
aus der Zeit des Todesfalls sowie einem
Artikel aus der Münchner Abendzeitung
bis zum nächsten mal euer Mirko und eure
Toni Redaktion und Produktion Stefan
Netzeband und Antonia Heyer
Postproduktion Wake Word Studios München